to keep us safe and free here  while we get this disease under control  across the whole world  we have been working on a program of  booster shots  again for over a year now and we've  backed some  of the only clinical trials in the world  looking specifically  at booster shots i'm delighted to be  able to tell you  that we've secured a further 60 million  doses of the pfizer beyond beyonce  vaccine  that will be used alongside others as  part of our booster shop program  later this year and that is  all about protecting the progress that  we've made  we have a clear route out of this crisis  but this is no time  for complacency it's a time for caution  so we can keep the virus under control  while we take the steps  safely back to normal life so please  remember that  the basics of hands face space and fresh  air  and crucially if  like me you get the call  join me and get the jab